it is important to me when I redid my
record deal when I upped with broken
boat for the first time that was a that
was a big point for me is I wanted to to
start owning my stuff and then when I
just react again I mean I wanted to own
more of it so you know it's it's
definitely something I mean I feel like
as the as the artist those are our
paintings that's our piece of art and
the record companies I mean I feel like
you know we both did well I made you
know these records they profited a lot
off of it and got that initial stuff off
of it and at some point you know I want
that stuff back and be able to to leave
to my family and sort of you know things
like that I mean I feel like it's very
important where's a gangster toes
covered in dirt just a rock and roll
t-shirt
with a pack of red
in his pocket he's kind of Redman
booties rocking we back was one that I
was at my house one day and Tyler
Hubbard just called me up and said hey
man we're going into write tomorrow I
know you're still cutting what are you
missing what do you need and as usual my
first responses I need some tip oh you
know and and so they went in the next
day and and a couple days later he text
me and said hey I'm sending you and I'm
sending you this song he sent it
[Music]
Tyler and BK both I mean they've written
some really cool stuff for us over the
years burning it down and you make it
easy
Morgan Weiland was only make it easy and
he's got one keeping a small town on the
new record I think when you're listing
my songs I mean you're always at least
for us because we tour so much I'm
always thinking about the live show and
you know how how songs are gonna work I
mean a lot of times you think about you
know you liked it in the past couple
albums we've had a lot of slower things
that we released so when you get to play
in your show a lot of times you start to
kind of feel like there's a little bit
of a lag in the show because there's so
many slow songs so it's like all right
man it's time for us to come back out
with some heat you can come with a tempo
and and so you know I think that's a
something you kind of got to balance a
little bit especially when you play live
as much as we do and you try to create
that big energetic show